Scarlett Johansson turns heads on the
red carpet in New York City while Ben
Affleck hits the red carpet in Las Vegas
for the first time since leaving rehab
[Music]
gamma and jewelry friendly Johansson
goes glam at the ghost in the shell
premiere wearing a custom sequined gown
you are the first of your kind et
chatted with the 32 year old actress
about pushing the limits in her role as
the major a sexy cyborg it's important
for me to continue to take on roles that
I feel challenged me in some way and you
know and keep trying to push whatever
boundary I set for myself that's
important being stepped out for his
first public appearance since announcing
he went to rehab for alcohol addiction
earlier this month the actor appeared
happy and healthy at cinemacon sporting
a dapper blue suit paired with a green
tie alongside his castmates a source
self ET quote everyone was excited to be
there and to show of what's to come with
Justice League one of those moments
where it was really just wonderful to
celebrate
[Music]
you